- I SAW ON THE NEWS TODAY,
TALKING ABOUT THE VIOLENCE
IN FOREIGN COUNTRIES.
TALKING ABOUT ALL THE SAVAGERY
UP IN THE WORLD,
BUT THEY AIN'T NEVER
TALK ABOUT SOUTH CENTRAL.
AIN'T NEVER TALK ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENED TO MY BROTHER.
NOW HE'S GONE.
NOW I AIN'T GOT NO BROTHER.
- YO, DOG.
I'LL BE YOUR BROTHER.
- REALLY?
- ABSOLUTELY, DOG.
YOU'RE GONNA NEED SOMEBODY
TO LEAN ON.
YOU CAN'T JUST BE
WALKING AROUND HERE
WITH THIS EMPTINESS
IN YOUR HEART, MAN.
AN EMPTINESS THAT CAN ONLY
BE FILLED BY A BROTHER.
- OKAY.
- BROTHERS, MAN?
- BROTHERS!
- GET IT IN HERE, DOG.
- COME OVER HERE.
- YOU GOT TO GET IT IN THERE,
DOG.
- I GOT TO TUCK IT, MAN.
[sighs]
- TUCK IT, TUCK IT, TUCK IT.
BROTHERS, MAN.
COME HERE, MAN.
WHY THE [bleep] YOU KEEP
FOLLOWING ME AROUND, MAN?
WHY DON'T YOU GO HOME
AND STAY OUT OF MY ROOM?
DON'T MESS WITH MY MODELS.
I'M ABOUT TO GET A WEDGIE UP
IN THIS MOTHER[bleep]
RIGHT HERE.
- WHAT THE--HEY!
HEY! GET THE [bleep]
OFF ME, MAN.
- GIVE ME THE WEDGIE--HEY.
- HEY.
YOU DON'T GIVE A GROWN MAN
A WEDGIE.
MOTHER[bleep],
I'M 34 YEARS OLD.
I GOT GRANDCHILDREN.